[Music]
a fan favorite theater Trope a scene
that explains the title and a hair metal
power fantasy all kids can relate to
Thor love and thunder is one bombastic
Marvel movie but these are the scenes
that most deserve a second watch warning
Major Spoilers ahead
the opening to Thor 11 Thunder is
interesting for how different it starts
from the usual Marvel movies for one it
is practically silent at the beginning
and there's no Marvel logo or Fanfare
the movie simply begins it's a
disorienting shot to the desert as the
camera Rises and turns we meet Christian
Bale's Gore just like in the comics that
inspired the film Gore is just a
desperate father seeking help from his
God to save his child it's
uncharacteristically somber and does an
excellent job of pulling you in it also
sets up a strange connection between
this film and Star Trek 5 the final
frontier that film also opens with a
weathered bald man in the desert also
Gore's goal is to reach the center of
the universe and have his wish granted
by The Entity referred to as eternity
that sounds suspiciously like Spock's
half-brother cybox plan to meet God at
the center of the Galaxy coincidence
perhaps watch both openings again though
and you might see the connection
all the high-flying wacky adventure
stuff you would expect from a guardian
to the Galaxy and Thor team up occurs
after Gore's origin and a quick rundown
of the previous film we learned that
Thor is done wandering around the cosmos
looking for people to save instead he
will sit and wait for someone to say
that they need his help to win this
battle
well if they say better late than not at
all
it's very nice Peter Quill says those
exact words and Thor rides on his ax
Stormbreaker like the Wicked Witch and
The Wizard of Oz before single-handedly
defeating the enemy it is a Bonker
sequence filled with humor and
incredible action it's got lasers Guns
and Roses Jim Henson as creatures
laughing and firing at Thor and
Jean-Claude Van Damme split and it's a
lot of fun to watch watching the
sequence is like seeing every 80s and
early 90s nerds dream of what a Thor
movie should be come to life it isn't
particularly insightful about the human
condition and it doesn't break a lot of
new ground regarding superhero action
but it's an absolute blast why wouldn't
you want to relive such a wild and
invigorating sequence more than once
Jane Foster isn't holding up so well in
Thor 11 Thunder she's still a brilliant
scientist using her intelligence to try
and save the world but she's also been
diagnosed with stage four cancer her old
friends Darcy and Selvig are the only
ones who know about her illness and
Darcy thinks Jane should reach out to
Thor while Jane doesn't want to do that
Thor's broken Hammer mjolnir is calling
out to her Jane travels to new Asgard in
Norway to find the hammer while she's
there as guardian actors just like in
Thor Ragnarok are performing a scene
from the previous movie they're doing
Odin's death scene and using every cheap
Stage production trick they can think of
to pull it off the scene is worth a
second viewing because it's hilarious
especially when Melissa McCarthy arrives
as hella and because it reminds viewers
that when an Asgardian dies and enters
Valhalla they disappear in wisps of gold
this time you can take in the funny
performances and appreciate the
foreshadowing of what will happen in the
final act with Jane
thanks to the trailers it comes as no
surprise that Natalie Portman's Jane
Foster would be wielding the power of
Thor in the film however the
anticipation for this moment is so
intense and the scene itself has so much
going on that when it finally happens
you're thrilled Jane
the acceleration of the sequence is what
really stands out it begins with Gore
arriving at new Asgard using his new
powers he creates Shadow creatures that
eerily stretch all along the Asgardian
streets when they start attacking Thor
Korg and King Valkyrie are there to
fight them off during the battle Thor
Hears A Familiar sound looking around
the chaos of battle he sees his
reconstructed mjolnir just as the hammer
is about to reach his hand it flies back
to its current Master Jane Foster things
turn into a violent and epic romantic
comedy as the two banter a bit before
Gore goes on the attack then we learn
this is all a ruse for Gore to capture
the children and hide them in the shadow
realm the seamless tonal shifts are very
impressive and the moment Jane holds me
only here is a stand-up and clap moment
with Thanos Marvel created someone who
is multi-dimensional with a point of
view you could understand even though
you probably don't agree with him
they've done this again in Thor love and
thunder in the form of Gore the god
butcher from his first appearance you
understand why he's so angry and
vengeful he was clearly a devoted
disciple of a God who betrayed him with
indifference that would be enough for us
to understand him but we empathize
because he's so complicated on a visual
level he looks haunted and creepy
however Christian Bale's voice isn't
Heavy Deep raspy in a few scenes his
voice is high pitched almost wounded for
instance take the scene in which he
emerges from the Shadows intentionally
terrifying the children he's captured by
producing a creature and ripping its
head off in a horrifying display of
dominance he doesn't smile he doesn't
laugh instead he looks sad tired and
confused it's worth watching again for
the shock of how dark the moment is and
to savor the nuances of the performance
since Gore exists in the shadow realm
Thor and Friends need to borrow Zeus's
weapon Thunderbolt to fight the darkness
this brings them to the incredible
omnipotent City where all the gods
reside everything about this place
deserves a re-watch because it is so
beautiful and packed with Easter eggs
and references at only multiple viewings
can fully reveal let's see who you are
and take off your disguise the star of
the show though is Russell Crowe Zeus to
call his performance over the top would
be an understatement he's devouring the
scenery around him like an
all-you-can-eat buffet and clearly
loving every second of it in a film this
wacky though it absolutely works and
Crow is an utter Delight
during their visit to omnipotent City
Our Heroes discover that Gore's goal is
to make it to the center of the universe
in order to reach a being called
eternity the legend says that the first
person to reach eternity will have their
wish granted since Gore's title is God
butcher Valkyrie implies that his wish
would be to wipe all gods out of
existence so they Journey to the shadow
realm to save the children and stop Gore
from getting his wish in a quest story
this would usually be the part where
everything slows down and the audience
gets a little bored waiting for
something to happen Thor love and
thunder keeps things interesting by
giving us Cosmic Vistas with space
Dolphins some World building regarding
the reproductive process of Quark
species and a warm heart to heart
between Thor and Jane
upon arriving in the shadow realm all
the color drains out of the film except
for Thunderbolts which still crackles
and sizzles with Zeus's power the
ominous nature of this mysterious Place
sets in right away and Thor's friends
are on the lookout for an ambush or any
signs of the children they're looking
for while journeying through the tunnels
deep within the Dark Moon Jane uncovers
Gore's plan he needs Stormbreaker to
conjure the bifrost in order to open the
gates to Eternity which kinda makes
sense considering how powerful the
bridge is according to Heimdall leave
the Bridge open would unleash the full
power of the bifrost and Destroy
newtonheim with new upon it the fact
that kidnapping Asgardian children was
all a ruse isn't surprising but that's
not the point of the scene the reason
this moment is so powerful is witnessing
just how brutal Gore can be he moves
through the Shadows like a reanimated
corpse he speaks through sharp rotten
teeth and even tortures Thor to make him
call his ax some viewers may not wish to
relive such an aggressively dark scene
but the strength of the performances
should be enough to bring it back
there was a time when the primary
audience for superhero stories was kids
adult fans may not like to admit this
fact but it's true as new creators
entered the comic book industry they
started updating their stories to
reflect their interests and eventually
superhero comics matured to a point
where most parents probably wouldn't
allow their kids to read them until
reaching some mutually agreed upon age
we have lived in this Paradigm for so
long that it's easy to forget the more
innocent origins of our favorite
characters family and kid-friendly
Comics still exist of course but the
vast majority of superhero films are
aimed at older audiences as why it is so
rewarding when Thor shares his powers
with the kidnapped children for the
first time in an MCU movie we see kids
take on the bad guys and it is pure
thrilling wish fulfillment as the song
November Rain kicks into gear the kids
Strike Back lightning erupts from their
eyes and weapons as they defeat their
captors and Thor does battle with Gore
for anyone who fell in love with
superheroes at a young age this is a
dream come true
like the opening the ending of Thor love
and thunder is surprisingly lacking in
the epic battle sequence Department
Marvel films have a habit of ending with
two super powered beans punching each
other into exhaustion and the one left
standing is the Victor but love and
thunder begins its climax that way
before careening into Uncharted
Territory for the MCU 4 reaches eternity
Jane is succumbing to her illness and
Thor doesn't know quite what to do
losing the love of his life and
witnessing her make the ultimate heroic
sacrifice he decides to open his heart
to four as a result Gore doesn't wish
for the end of the Gods like he planned
instead eternity brings his daughter
back Thor inspired by the villain's
drive to honor his daughter at all costs
proves to him that the reason for living
has always been love if you're tired of
loud raucous and tedious finales this
ending should come as a breath of fresh
air and it's well worth the second
viewing at the very least it should help
explain to any confused viewers why the
film is called love and Thunder
everyone knows to stick around during
the credits of a Marvel movie since Nick
Fury introduced himself to Tony Stark at
the end of the original Iron Man and has
become a tradition with each installment
to stay in your seats and see what teas
they have in store for the next movie in
the case of Thor love and thunder we get
two scenes One lets us know that Jane
made it to Valhalla where she is greeted
by Heimdall the other sets up a very
exciting antagonist for the next film
the scene begins with a wounded Zeus
lamenting people's lack of interest in
the gods he can remember a time when
humans feared and worshiped them now all
they care about are superheroes fed up
with this fall from grace he vows to
make them fear the gods once again the
suggestion that a new Thor movie
featuring God's terrorizing humanity is
cool enough but the final reveal is the
real kicker it turns out that Zeus
wasn't simply talking to himself he was
giving orders to his son Hercules then
we see that Brett Goldstein who played
Roy Kent and Ted lasso is playing the
legendary son of Zeus watching the son
of Odin and the son of Zeus duking out
is going to be a blast and this scene
builds the hype perfectly check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]